look that way can I without looking at
me answer this question where do women
with no legs work I don't know I don't
know either but it's crawling with [ __ ]
[Laughter]
okay well the [ __ ] world seems to be
upside down and [ __ ] sucks but I can't
lie man I am thrilled that this podcast
is gaining steam and each episode doing
better than the one before and this one
is a hammer oh [ __ ] I don't even need to
promote it
it's [ __ ] Ronda Rousey yeah
ladies and gentlemen Ronda Rousey
suffice it to say that I have been like
unreasonably excited about doing this
and when I was going to bed with my girl
last night I told her I was like I was
like babe I'm like I feel like such a
dork
because I've been so excited I've been
barage in Ronda with texts like to the
point where she's probably thinking like
why did I give this kook my phone number
and then and then I showed I showed Lux
the actual text blog where I'm like look
I might write all these big long things
and I scrolled through it and she goes
oh my she's like oh my god but then she
but then she said you know it's just
it's kind of cute that you're so excited
so I don't think anybody should should
be mad at you or feel bad somehow
because yeah we were gonna do a social
distancing podcast and then [ __ ] got
even crazier and so I'm glad we were
able to like evolve times and I guess
our amazing van
somehow yeah thank you
yeah and it was so crazy because Lux and
I were over at your house for a double
date like when was that was that like
two babes three weeks that was like the
weekend before [ __ ] got gnarly right
except member I walked in and to give
you an an elbow bump yeah inaudible
right and the reason why that the reason
why I wanted to be careful about an
elbow bump is because I had been touring
like for weeks straight and done meet
and greets with like the entire audience
after every show so like I thought well
[ __ ] if if anybody is gonna have
coronavirus it'll be me I wanted to be
social distancing at that point not
because I was worried about myself but
just because the idea of spreading it in
general is too scary yeah it is I like
my sister like had her birthday or
something in New York like right before
like her school got cut out so she was
home and then my other sister was there
cuz I can't bring my baby over and I'm
like nah man you're the co Julia and
like I don't know she was just in New
York and it's like a hotbed and then
yeah none of my family has been allowed
to come over like we're on a hundred
percent like lockdown you were the last
person to come to my house I believe it
yeah I totally believe it and thank you
again for having us over
oh yeah I'm wearing my Ronda Rousey
t-shirt veggie burgers I planted both of
the like the little bit leftover heads
at root balls and now they're like
growing and everything I love it well
it's like the Steve Ott lettuce I always
like think of you and I go to my garden
right which which brings us to the first
and most important thing to talk about
which is your sustainable approach to
living and and growing and harvesting
your own food right like you've been
preparing for exactly this kind of a
situation like doomsday in general
you're a prepper
yeah I've been in like a proper 4 years
and like III really never wanted to say
like I told you so or anything like that
but I mean we've been like kind of like
obsessively getting ready and just kind
of like waiting for the fall Society and
I think it's gonna happen in stages like
this is like the first wave man oh my
god it's so scary I mean I don't wanna
like bomb everybody out but like the
other night I plugged into my youtube
search the two words Great Depression I
thought you know maybe like there's some
videos to put into context like what
we're facing right now and the general
consensus seemed to be that this looks
like a greater depression than the Great
Depression and it's just so scary to
think of that and and I mean [ __ ] so
here we are the good thing is you know
humanity has survived all of the
craziest things that have happened you
know like the Depression saw through a
banach plague sucks like world war 1 & 2
sucked but you know right we're very
hard to eliminate you know and so I
think it's more than like being like oh
no this is terrible we're not in like
the cushiest times I think it just kind
of happens in cycles especially with us
like reproducing so quickly and like
taking over so much the planet and
everything and so it's kind of a one of
those things where we can all get that
victim mentality or we could think about
like okay how can we like evolve with
the times and how can we take the
initiative and you know instead of
Welling dwelling in our situation like
take the initiative and find a way to
get out of it right right and and and I
love everything that you just said and
it reminded it reminded me of some great
stuff that you said when we were
recording for your YouTube channel which
we should just plug right away because I
think most of my podcast listeners are
actually watching on YouTube so be very
easy for them to click over and
subscribe to your YouTube channel which
is it's just Ronda Rousey
but yeah you're my favorite go walk ever
we like actually pick it up into two
episodes you're just an amazing person
to talk to you and well thank you and
and I feel like I've started this off in
a super dark and depressing way and I
don't want to like the people listening
to be bummed out so let's make this fun
like very quickly I'm dying to ask you a
bunch of questions but the one that is
particularly on my mind a lot of people
came to this from watching my ridiculous
World Records video and absolutely I
know for a fact that I've been asked by
more dudes to kick them in the nuts guys
begged me they're like dude is there any
way I could get you to kick me in the
nuts and so it makes me wonder if like
what's the most common thing that people
ask you like do people come up to you
and say dude can you choke me
unconscious do you get that a lot yeah
people ask me to choke of an armbar
though like all the time people yeah
really yeah I just tell them it's like a
really expensive PhD you can't just like
give them out like you know no that's
well I mean that's the I guess it's
probably more comparable to the neck
kick there are two things nobody in
their right mind would ever want like a
Ronda Rousey armbar or a kick in the
nuts period yeah II like kind of develop
like I'd kind of like like oh here's
like my fake photo armbar you know
uh-huh
I'm just like make him happy but no one
really wants the real thing they don't
know what they're getting into
right Fred did did you really break
Miesha Tate arm oh yeah that was that
would be like the elbow had wrinkles on
the wrong side wow that's crazy because
you know like I mean I gotta just tell
you like a huge part of the reason why
I'm so excited to do this with you is
because I'm such a huge fan you in fact
got me into MMA where before I just
didn't give a
[ __ ] about it at all I mean I used to
work in in a video store reshelving the
rented VHS tapes and there was a whole
little section for this was 1996 and UFC
started in 93 there's a whole section of
Ultimate Fighting and I tried to watch
it at one point and I was just like man
all this like laying on the car because
they didn't have rounds you know I was
so like so the grappling exchanges would
would be like really really long and I
found it boring you know like of course
now I'm like such a crazy fan like I
love all the grappling but but yeah I'm
one of millions of people who have
become like a die-hard UFC fan like
purely because of you I appreciate that
I actually have like a very different
grappling background from most people
because I came from judo and the guys
that you're watching came from jiu-jitsu
where they had a limited time on the
ground and unless you had a background
in jujitsu you wouldn't really know what
you were looking at and so it's like
these guys do it it's boring it looks
gay like so you know like all these
people had these preconceived notions
about it but I came from Olympic judo
which you know what has very biased
officiating and so like they a lot of
the times would give me like one second
even to work from on the ground or to
you know I like had to constantly making
progress or they would make me stand up
and so I kind of always felt like I was
fighting against my opponent and the
referee you know so it kind of had to
make every match into a fight in order
to win and I had to be able to
transition into an armbar and a finish
right away on the ground because that
was the most definite way to win if you
were choking somebody out and they make
you stand up well that person just takes
deep breaths and they're fine and for
putting somebody and then make you stand
up well they're absolutely fine but if
you break somebody's arm and they make
you stand up [ __ ] has a broken arm and
if you still lose after that then you're
the [ __ ] I think that's the kind of
thing that my mom would teach me as a
kid so she would be like every single
match everything that you're doing every
single time that you hit the crowd you
are going
- breaking the arm as best as you can
and that was kind of like how I was
drilled to think of a very very young
age like young as like 12 I'm almost
like okay
it was time for you to start doing our
bars and that was always the goal in
every exchange was it starts with I get
my hands on you
we're gonna get to the ground at some
point and as soon as we hit the ground I
should be trying to break your hair
immediately so how many arms do you
think you've broken man I don't know
when I was like younger when I was like
in my teens I would count that kind of
thing and feel cool and then after a
while I'm like if you're still counting
you're an [ __ ] like I don't know the
moral of the story is that like it's
only cool to break so many arms that you
lose count I realize like that's not the
kind of thing to feel cool for you know
like yeah I like grew out of it like you
know could call me petty call me
self-absorbed but if I had broken
multiple arms I would like not only be
counting back I would feel so [ __ ]
cool breaking it so much is like a lot
of times like you're dislocating the
joint hyperextending yeah like you can
like you can feel it like popping and
going out of like the socket like I used
to relate it to like tearing off turkey
legs you know you kind of like feel it
it's just like a weak joint in general
it's not like your shoulder that's like
a ball joint or like your hip it's a
ball joint like it has very limited
range and then past that range it takes
very little push it past that so I mean
I've had my elbows dislocated hundreds
of times hundreds of times to the point
that like like all my ligaments here are
super loose like I've been arm part when
I was younger and I was like I've
invisible you know whatever like I'm
just gonna let you pop my arm out and
then my arms gonna be like malleable and
I can slip out and then I didn't realize
that even though you feel better in a
few weeks when you're 16 when you're in
your thirties it comes back
yeah I got to be like when I did judo
you would have like grips it had like an
inside grip and a lot of times the stone
had an inside curve which is dominant
grip you would try to bring your elbow
over and put their arm to the outside so
it was kind of like a chess game with
like gripping and if my arm was slightly
turned like this was someone else did
that heroin diss okay and I would have
to like pop my elbow back and all the
time it would be dislocating all the
time so like to me like dislocating
somebody's arm is not that big of a deal
because it happened to be all of the
time so certain said let me ask you this
the the UFC is I mean it's certainly
such a huge like organization it's such
a it's become mainstream but is the WWE
not just way big or like did you get the
sense when you went into the WWE like
wow like way more people are huge fans
of WWE well I think WWE has like a
history and very like a
multi-generational you know so like to
some people it's like it's like a
religion to them almost but it's also
very closed off you know like and it's
getting away from there you know they're
starting to get like bigger television
deals and all this stuff and like actual
sports coverage and things like that but
like um if you watch UFC and you're
seeing two people fighting you
understand what's going on muta Li you
know like that guy is fighting that guy
that guy hit that guy in the face ouch
that guy not that guy out that guy won
the like I get you know you don't really
get to have it explained to you but I
think there's just so many intricacies
to the WWE that would it's presented as
is actually nowhere near as fascinating
and multi fascinators what is all that
multifaceted as what it actually is and
by intricacies do you mean like
storylines and stuff is that right I
like storylines and structure and like
what's going on because like I was
getting back into WWE because Shana was
like
the she knew how to actually operate my
television and I didn't and we were all
like living together said you said Shana
Shana a Shayna Baszler and who's that
Shana BAE's this one the four horse of n
okay she was just in WrestleMania
actually yesterday totally got screwed
over but you know let's not go there
haha how did they do WrestleMania
yesterday they didn't have anybody in
the crowd no it was like entirely
pre-taped it's a two-day event I think
it's still going on today I do a lot of
cross programming with myself apparently
yeah I think like WWE is kind of you
need like someone almost like Sherpa you
like through it to get it and understand
it what's going on because if you just
watch a match even if it was one of the
greatest matches of all time you can
very obviously tell that it's scripted
and is staged and it loses a lot of
people there so I think it's like WWE
has it's very hardcore fanbase and not
really that much in between I told you
about how I was in the WWE ring on
Monday Night Raw and I strongly suspect
that they went like harder on me they're
the one guy Umaga I mean granted of
course because the match was supposed to
be over and I kept moving around and
that I didn't realize is a sign of
disrespect and so we really like beat me
into a blackout I'd actually do not
remember leaving the ring but even
before that earlier in the match I
suspected that the he was like maybe
making some kind of a point I've heard
somebody suggest that when like
celebrities are like you know non like
real wrestlers get in the ring that they
almost like go harder on them like
they're like I want to make it well I
mean there's just so many unspoken rules
there's so much unspoken that like
everyone's expected to know but like how
the hell are you supposed to know kind
of a thing
and I think there's also
like a chip on people's shoulder
thinking that they don't get the respect
that they deserve for what they do so a
lot of right from outside and they think
like oh yeah this is whatever tip to
have [ __ ] think whatever's and
people kind of have that chip on their
shoulder to prove to them like hey this
is tough stuff and this is something you
should take seriously and there was like
you know these unspoken rules like you
were saying you're trying to flail
around and show oh my god this hurt so
much but you were supposed to lay dead
but because you didn't know that
unspoken rule they beat the SH out of
you until you lay down which is like
kind of what I don't know like in like
pro wrestling there's like I could
almost like a hazing to kind of get you
to think a way that they want you to
think and adapt top to system and weight
thinking and so if you kind of like walk
into the back door and you don't know
any of that there's just so much of like
like a etiquette that makes perfect
sense that makes total sense and of
course like they're not going to be like
harder on like you know random
celebrities that go in there but when
it's like a couple [ __ ] from jackass
saying that word like the toughest stunt
people
of course they went so hard on us so
yeah that makes sense
okay now I've gotten another question
and and this you got to forgive my
ignorance for this one and maybe it's
not even an appropriate question to
begin with but as a guy i have to say
i'm just curious and fascinated about
the idea of with women's fighting if
let's say you're big huge fight you know
you're headlining an event and it just
so happens to land during the week that
you have your period was i nervous to
ask that question yes and before we find
out how it went over I'm gonna make a
crazy promise to all of you okay here
goes if you see me in public
anywhere for the rest of this calendar
here it's like eight or nine months I
guarantee you I will have something in
my pocket okay my ray
Kahn earbuds and I'll tell you why I'm
gonna have them in my pocket oh and by
the way should I not I will record your
voicemail greeting on your iPhone I'll
record a video shoutout for your buddies
whatever but I'm not even worried about
it because I love these things so much
they're always in my pocket or my ears
that counts too and why do I love them
so much
well other earbuds I'm not gonna name
names but none of them have a button to
skip track pause right like hang up the
phone like how is that possible these
cost half the price sound every bit as
good and they have the button to control
it plus they're no bigger than any of
the other ones it's crazy how they
charged in the case
they somehow know exactly like when you
pull them out to turn on they fit in
your ears so well you can take your
shirt on and off they won't fall out you
can do all kinds of exercise you can
like they're so comfortable and just fit
in there so well and I mean I literally
love them so again I guarantee you they
will always be in my pocket
ears or both mostly both okay now here's
the big deal for you guys if you go to
buy rakin comm slash steve-o 15% off
your order
and it's like already half the price of
any of the other ones so dude rake on
you rule I love you thank you so much
and now what's it like for women to fist
fight on their period let's find out how
does that like influence the performance
or the fight your weight cut is harder
and your titties are bigger if you check
out my fight against Alexis Davis you
will see an example of that yeah it just
makes the weight cut harder okay that's
why I always wore black shorts because I
was always really [ __ ] paranoid about
that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and Mike Tyson wear black shorts I was
like oh that's cool but also like what
if it's the wrong day those white shorts
is scary I ain't gone anywhere near that
[ __ ] that's that's hilarious yeah I was
I was I was asking Lux last night I was
like I said if like [ __ ] up if I asked
this question and she wasn't like you
know feeling strongly one way or the
other but then I said you know well I
was you know I can tell Rhonda that from
my experience particularly with Lux if
the fight landed in like the days just
leading up to before the period started
that that would give Lux like a huge
advantage like goddammit I had like a
string of fights from like statistically
[ __ ] impossible like why am i like my
weight cuts always this hard like yeah
it's just kind of roll the dice and it's
like sometimes women [ __ ] just tap it's
the wrong time did you ever deal with
that I had I had a chick show up and
she's like I can't make weight cuz I'm
on my period I'm like [ __ ] you that's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] answer you know
that you had a vagina when he signed up
for this like he can't act like you
weren't ineligible to fight 1/4 of your
life [ __ ] off make wait don't be a [ __ ]
then so it that's so interesting to me
because I mean [ __ ] it it would imagine
I would imagine that you would hear that
excuse all the time from like female
fighters missing wait like tatianna
Suarez missed weight by like seven and a
half pounds I think one time like she
didn't even say yo I'm on the rag
dude there's really no excuse to cut
weight you're a professional you know
when the match is gonna be like you were
paid to show up and make weight on that
day and if you are unable to do that
then don't promise that you're gonna do
it you know like but you know I have
like a different perspective about it
I the only time I missed weight in judo
I moved up to the next division the very
next tournament and I never went back
down again because I'm like well guess
can't make this [ __ ] away anymore you
know and that's it
it's uh you got to show up and you got
to do your job we're professionals if
you're not professional and like what
the [ __ ] you doing there right now what
I've heard people say that that weight
cutting is like generally like a really
like sort of dangerous like harmful
thing that the you know what are your
thoughts about that like is there well
it's as harmful as you decide to make it
be you know like you are at the freedom
to choose whatever division you want to
be in and if you feel like it's harmful
for you to go below a certain weight
then don't attempt to go below that
weight fight up all right you're not a
[ __ ] slave dude like it's a free
country pick the way that's healthiest
for you and become the biggest badass at
that like I don't see the difficulty
there I mean I I've definitely had
really really hard times cutting weight
I have definitely had like good days and
bad days days when I was fighting too
much and didn't have enough time to
recover and you know my performance
definitely suffered from it different
times but I never blamed anybody else
for that you know it was my decision to
take that fire that time my decision to
do it that way if everything was my
decision and so everything was my
responsibility and I never like pushed
it off you know pushed off my
responsibility in those situations to
victim of my situation because I'm in a
situation of my own creation right and I
love that that position that you take it
again reminds me of when we were
recording for your YouTube channel and I
told you about a documentary I watched
on Netflix called the hurt business I
think and of Daniel Cormier was a big
part of it and I bring it up because it
had such a
found impact on me we're like the the
overall kind of message that I got is
that when you look at like MMA UFC like
any one of these MMA organizations that
like really the norm is that people
don't make all that much money
like they end up like with like [ __ ]
brain trauma
you know like [ __ ] up brains like
[ __ ] up bodies and then at the end of
their careers which don't tend to run
very long they're in like physically
horrible [ __ ] shape and they have
absolutely nothing to show for it
because they because they didn't make
really much money to get by on anyway
and it was I was so interested by the
way that you responded to that like very
you know you said well you mean you can
say it again the the odd the alternative
coming out of the Olympics is you make
nothing you know that here you said that
in the UFC and all these MMA
organizations give you an opportunity as
an athlete to make a living which
otherwise you wouldn't I mean I walked
out of the Olympics with you know a
bronze medal and I was I knew that I am
the baddest [ __ ] on the planet you know
and if there anybody trying to start
[ __ ] with you if I could take him down
and break their arm in a second and
nobody gave a [ __ ] it was a completely
useless skill the only job had helped me
get is as a cocktail waitress in
Crenshaw because they thought I could
you know defend myself what I'm going to
do with that
I spent the amount of time and energy on
trying to develop those skills as anyone
spends on a degree or a PhD but there
was no career out there for me so I had
to create a career for myself for the
skill set that I had because in any kind
of workplace it was completely useless
and so all these other people that are
former Olympic athletes would have
otherwise had nothing they would have
ended up you know having to start all
over with no education and work
experience because if he's devote your
life to a sport of the Olympics after
it's over you're behind
and you didn't make [ __ ] off the [ __ ]
Olympics yes yes what you make less
money on than the than the UFC [ __ ]
the Olympics a costume money okay right
and then a bunch of any other countries
they like give you a house in the car
and some gratitude or whatever and you
know I bitched about it so much they got
rid of taxing people for their the prize
money for Olympic medals but I got a
bronze medal and Cheetos but my whole
life doing it they gave me ten grand
text me on it that was six grand and I
couldn't even get a used Honda Accord
for that like fog that's what I had to
show for that [ __ ] and people are
bitching about being able to like like
make a living from their skills doing
the UFC like no one told you it was a
[ __ ] pillow fight know how dangerous
it is and it's just like you know like
there's much more dangerous things it's
a lot of the injuries an anime or
cosmetic you know you usually get cut or
something before you really start
getting crazy brain damage like as
opposed to like boxing where you win by
neurological injury this person gets
knocked out an accountant ten over and
over and over yeah diet boxing every
year dying you know football because
they have a helmet protect them and they
have this you know brain suspended in a
fluid and all this force and everything
like of all the different options out
there I was like man MMA looks so great
I'm gonna try and find a way to get
myself in there you know like it was the
best option I could find at the time I
mean like I don't feel that bad for
people are like oh [ __ ] man I got it was
really rough on my body and it didn't
really work out like well no one
guaranteed that [ __ ] was gonna work out
and of course [ __ ] him drop on your
body were you watching it did you see
like there was any false pretences like
he knew what you're getting
- yeah there's much history and seeing
like the long-term effects what happens
people but you're also very [ __ ]
aware that like you know that you're
jumping into the pool and you're the
first [ __ ] swimmers and who knows
what's gonna happen in the long run but
no one's sold it is anything different
right you know so these are all like our
conscious choices and all of our
consequences that we chose to live with
it wasn't right it presented as anything
else it's such an interesting point that
you make that people die in boxing all
the time and nobody has died from MMA is
that right just seven people died like a
year from boxing or something like that
I could have made that statistic up but
it seems good seems about right but I
think like a couple people maybe like
one or two have died doing it but not in
the UFC dude people have died doing judo
you know like people have ended up
paralyzed from the neck down diving and
doing a new ciabatta and you know people
died doing gymnastics from doing that
[ __ ] roundoff thing into the horse
and they tuck their head and then they
can't move for the neck down like it's a
dangerous [ __ ] world out there I
don't know what you want me to tell you
right I'm with you yeah I mean I think
it's a certain kind of person that
should go into that lifestyle and if
that risk is something that you're not
willing to deal with then dude you're
not gonna go that far because it's not
that important to you you have to be
willing to die to be the best in order
to be the best it has to like be
something that is that much a part of
you in order for you to get far enough
for you to make a living anyway and if
you're in that fuzzy in-between zone
dude go to school please yeah hi babe
yeah how's it going Travis dude now both
the UFC and the WWE have been widely
criticized for not paying their athletes
their talent
I'm much I think it just came out of
statistic that of the revenue that the
UFC brings in
sixteen percent goes to the fighters and
whereas in other sports like basketball
football / it's like well over 50
percent or there's something to that
kind of magnitude so I'm just like I
again probably totally an appropriate
question but like which is the more
generous company to its athletes well I
think that comes with the age of the
sport do you know the older the sport is
the more that the athletes can really
start to like kind of come together and
get and fight for what they think they
deserve as unified front so with the WWE
being older they definitely have like
they have like developmental programs so
they bring people in to like live and
train by the PC in Orlando we get a
salary and they get all you know
unlimited access doctors and you know
physical therapists all these different
things that you know as an Olympian I
would have died that you know and so
happy to have something like that UFC
originally you know didn't have anything
like that and then they started moving
towards okay we're getting some kind of
like medical insurance because used to
be like okay you're only gonna get
covered for injuries that come up within
60 days of a fight and then okay weird
now we're gonna get some sort of medical
insurance but it's not the best in the
world and okay like no we're starting to
make like more and more and more and in
boxing like the top guys make an
incredible amount of money but the
bottom guys in boxing make it way way
less than the bottom guys in the UFC
okay so like if you're trying to develop
a boxer and you know regularly you're
probably have to build their record to
20 in something and your manager is
gonna probably be like $200,000 in the
hole with a fighter that's 20 you know
at that point Wow
in the UFC it's a lot nicer to kind of
be in that lower tier than it is to be a
boxer but at the time
tear in boxing these guys are making
incredible amount of monies because they
they are promoting as well they are Co
promoting they're part of the promotion
itself and I just I think that as as the
sports get older the athletes get wiser
they get some more resources they start
to realize how the system really works
they're gonna be able to get more and
more like when I started coming up in
the OSI there was no set precedent for
me to marry make big demands about okay
this is what I'm worth this is what I
should get this is my pay-per-view cut
this is not because there was no right
data for me to point out no reason it
was all speculation and it's very
difficult in individual sports so like
football and basketball these guys and
the whole team and come together be like
hey us as a team we are not going to do
this unless they as the team owners do
this and it's much easier for them to
come together and make those demands
whereas like individual sports like
boxing and UFC and WWE which is sports
entertainment but still is individual
it's much easier to kind of divide
people and much harder for them to to
unite together because people at the
very top are very well taken care of you
know so it's um I think hard harder for
them to kind of unionize and make sure
everybody else is really looks looked
after and gets the majority share in in
the profits at the end of the day so I
don't know I think this is a constantly
evolving situation okay as a devil's
advocate can I see what you think about
you know as the sport gets older you
know it's an opportunity for the
athletes to get better taken care of but
then again as the UFC has gotten older
we no longer see individual athletes
with sponsors on their clothing it's all
Reebok and the athletes get nothing from
that so is there also not a component of
like backsliding as the sport gets older
oh I mean it's not that they get nothing
it's everybody gets a split share so
instead of having like a whole bunch of
people having individual sponsors all
over themselves everybody gets a share
of the Reebok sponsor whatever they're
paying which you know probably
represents a step backwards as it pours
too but if you think about it like are
any of the NFL players allowed to have
individual sponsorships to see the
basketball players allowed to put you
know condom depot.com
it gets to a point where like WWE are
you allowed to come out with like you
know guns are us on your titties like I
it's it's kind of like the standard
that's been set by other sports you win
the UFC was unique in that and they were
kind of like when they were smaller that
was part of the hustle and you know like
as they got bigger and more mainstream
some of those smaller characteristics
kind of got lost because if they want to
be looked at on the same level as the
NBA and the NFL [ __ ] you know
baseball and all that [ __ ] they have to
kind of adopt their model a little bit
more and I would like to see you know
bigger sponsors and more money getting
like bigger deals being made so that
what is being split up and divvied up
between all of the fighters is actually
you know gets to be more and more and
more and more juice um that I hope will
mature along with the sport but you know
who knows I love it that is makes so
much sense I'm actually embarrassed for
making that part so now so you went into
the WWE and he only did one year one
year from mania know mania and was that
I mean you told me a little bit about
this when we were walking your goats
that you are thinking about now you and
Travis want to have kids you would like
you'd like just it's too much to be
traveling so much and working so much at
the WWE that he really wanted to kind of
take back your life so that you could
have like a personal life and a quality
of life but that's gotta be a pretty
serious sacrifice right like financially
I mean not really like we try to think
that we don't really do anything for
purely money related reasons mm-hmm we
tried to reduce our expenses as much as
possible because all of the money that
we make is dependent on the mileage that
we put on our bodies and how much of
that do we have you know so right we
invest our money not into having more
[ __ ] that we have to pay to maintain but
in in needing less so the money that we
made from fighting and wrestling and all
this other stuff we put into okay we're
going to get water-catchment there we're
an Eliminator water bill and we're gonna
get solar and we're gonna eliminate our
electric bill and we're gonna pay house
cash so we're gonna live in a mortgage
and we're going to you know get a bunch
of chickens and graze our own animals
and start you know our own vegetables
all this stuff so we get to eliminate
our grocery bill and so instead of
having to like think in that mindset of
like what I wanted what are we gonna be
able to do to be able to bring enough
money to maintain our lifestyle right
and I'm like how can we slim our
lifestyle more and more and more down to
take less and less and less to maintain
so that the decisions that we make in
our lifestyle are purely based on what
makes us happy that is what has to be
done that is so inspiring I honestly
like and legitimately like jealous and
inspired and and I want to tell you that
I've gone on and on and on with my
social media and you know like
everywhere anyone it will listen and say
oh my girl and I we want to buy land and
open up our own Animal Sanctuary and
we're so serious about this that were
whereas we're even though we're engaged
we are waiting to get married we've not
even said
date because we want to get married on
our land where we're gonna have our
animal sanctuary because that's our
future you know I got a vasectomy so
that we know we're not gonna have kids
I'm a reverse mastectomy baby I mean
yeah I'm not reversing it I don't want
it I don't want to do it but but the
point that I'm making here and I want to
really thank you for this is that you
have single-handedly changed my view of
what of what the animal sanctuary
represents to me because what you are
doing with your property which you call
browse II acres and everything that you
just described with you know catching
the water and the solar and the growing
the vegetables and the eggs and and the
animals that to me makes so much more
sense as really the ultimate purpose of
our Animal Sanctuary you know I like
sure we want to save a bunch of animals
who are in it but like to have it be
like just a self-sustainable like bill
eliminating thing where it's like yeah
come on down and hang out but you know
but you got to work almost like a
commune yeah but it doesn't like feel
like work it's like really rewarding
stuff that I actually want to spend my
day doing this and so like it's kind of
got to the point where we love it so
much that it it's like a tax to leave
you know like I love the WWE I had such
a great time I love all the girls locker
room like hell yeah like running out
there you know having like big fights
for fun is just the best thing you know
like I love choreography I love acting I
love theater and let's live theater and
so the last forms of live theater and
it's so fun but it was like I was doing
it basically part time and I was away
from home over 200 days out of the year
and I did get home like I basically I
was like I was so sleep-deprived like
because you just don't have time to lay
down and like my back's broke so I am
like coming home like ah what do you
mean you're back
my bottom vertebrae is like broke it in
half when they like they got me like a
praise like a house before I came that
WWE they're like yeah your backs broke
like oh [ __ ] know that so um I would be
taking all these different kinds of
bombs and stuff and I would basically
when I was home I would have to be
laying on the bed with my legs elevated
the heat pack under my back with like a
tempurpedic pillow under my neck because
I've generated dis disorder in my neck
as well as on me - like I was like in
this like recovery position whenever I
was home so I wasn't even home when I
was home I was basically just trying to
recover enough to be able to get through
the next stint of being gone and like
people think like oh you're only
wrestling as much as you see you on TV
but they don't realize that there's like
three four other days of live shows
during the week so we're only home like
if I would did all of the live shows
I was holding home a day and a half a
week man it was just like not worth it
for my family cuz we because we were
eliminating all of our expenses living
in this lifestyle we you know we didn't
need it
we didn't need the money so it's just
like what am I doing it for if I am NOT
being able to spend my time and my
energy on my family but instead spending
my time on energy on a bunch of [ __ ]
ungrateful fans that don't appreciate me
so I am I mean I'm like and the thing is
like I love performing I love the girls
I love being out there but at the end of
the day I was just like [ __ ] these fans
dude my family loves me and they
appreciate me and I want them all my
energy to go into them so that was my
decision at the end of the day is like
hey girls love which doing I'm gonna try
and like take all on momentum and push
you guys as far as I can fly - the birds
fly I'm gonna go and [ __ ] at home and so
that's that's like a it sounds pretty
conclusive that you're not trying to go
back well if I ever do come back it
never be at a full-time capacity every
guy they made me come back for
Wrestlemania I think like for like
stints like chunks of time you know I'm
very much like an obsessive person or I
like to obsess over something for a
certain time and then like kind of go
take some time to obsess about something
else but know I'm never gonna be full
time again over 200 days a year on the
road like that ever again because it's
just it was I needed to do it in order
to learn and get like immersed into it
and really understand what was going on
but it's just not the lifestyle for me
okay you said that boxer that the boxer
is the lower tier guys really don't do
well while the top tier guys dude like
explosively well and the UFC was a
better version of that where the lower
tier guys are you know proportionally
doing better how does the WWE fit into
that and sort of a structure that maybe
is even better because everyone's on
salary it's not like you show up for a
fight you get paid you show for a fight
you get paid so like I think in WWE that
actually considered employees instead of
independent contractors but I'm not sure
I think they are independent country I
said yeah but they're treated like
employees they're casually are on a
salary and it is much more like secure
or like if people like get injured and
they can't perform for like months and
months and months on end they actually
continue to pay them and pay for their
medical treatment and like you know make
sure that they're taking care of Corey
graves is a great example of somebody
who I ended up getting too many
concussions while he was in the
development program and so they
transitioned him to be an announcer
instead like they really tried their
best not to lead people high and dry
and they really like invest in talent
and spend time on building and
developing them when they come through
the PC you know people that come through
the indie system it's a little bit
different but they also put them through
the PC and you know like bring when as
soon as they hire people there they're
on salary right away which
is very very different than having like
these lumps of prize money so it's like
I would say that it's definitely the
most secure and job like of the three I
gotta say that it sounds to me a little
bit like the Olympics set your standard
solo because say that because I watched
a John Oliver said like 20 minute long
segment about professional wrestling and
his whole tone his whole take on it was
so completely the opposite of what
you're talking about
and the only way that I can make sense
of it is that oh because John Oliver's
got like these impossibly high standards
of life and Ronda Rousey like came from
the Olympics and that Olympics yeah is
some [ __ ] so for everything more
than that oh wow what I would like to
see from all three which is kind of like
some wishful thinking that I don't think
will ever happen it's similar to like to
like sad or something like that whereas
if you put a certain amount of time in
you are entitled to a pension I would
love to see pensions for good boxers and
MMA fighters and professional wrestlers
I don't know if we're gonna get there
but I mean that's what you know the NBA
and the NFL and [ __ ] right baseball
and hockey you all have and that's what
I would love for people to have to at
least have to strive for is like oh I
just want to put enough time in to be
eligible for a pension and then have a
living wage the rest of my life that's
that would be like my ultimate like
dream goal for all three of the
individual like big players good for the
people listening who did not come from
my world records video can we please
give some appreciation
to your incredible world record for and
tell me if I'm saying it right you are
the only person in the history to have
won championships in Strikeforce
the UFC the WWE and won an Olympic medal
yeah that's one I can I can claim that
one unbelievable it's your [ __ ]
superstar there's no two ways about it
and I didn't get a resolution for my
question how many people have you choked
out choked out well you know actually
like a really weak wrists so like in in
mm I'm getting judo like the palette is
really really thick it's not like you
just see where it's kind of like thin
like pajamas so I tapped a few people
out some chokes but I've never really
choked I'm sure not they can give up
it's a it's a yeah it's not a party
trick that you do know man I'm so afraid
of getting sued right I have been choked
out by a bunch of people including gene
LeBell hell yeah he said that's an honor
I've never took to anybody else out okay
so and now gene LeBell is such a huge
person in your story and just mentioning
his name singing he smiles so much as
his killer for people who don't know
gene LeBell like how do you like what
uncle gene is pretty much the most
decorated stuntman the whole time he was
he did fights with Bruce Lee and John
Wayne all the way up to rush hour and he
was in the first-ever televised and I'm
a match because his mom was a promoter a
boxing promoter and set up a boxing
versus judo televised match that he won
by the way and and and before that he
was the world champion of joy of Judo I
don't know see
on the worlds but like my mom said that
like every tournament they used to have
like Grand Slam champion where they
would have like all of the people who
won all of the divisions fight again
against each other and he would win that
all the time I don't think she ever saw
him lose he was like a badass before you
know that my mom looked up to back when
she was competing back in the day but I
don't think he ever even like competed
in the worlds or anything like that it
wasn't like his big of a deal you know
like it was kind of like building it up
into being a big deal you know he was
more like here he never really pursued
athletics that much and I will recount
to you uncle genes advice to me because
he kept trying to convince me to love
doing MMA and do stunts it goes you know
good I have won every re-al fight I
never made a penny but I lost every ar e
IL fight and I am comfortably retired
and he basically was like don't waste to
talk about sports yeah is it true that
that Brad Pitt's character in Quentin
Tarantino's movie once upon a time in
Hollywood is based on gene LeBell I
wouldn't doubt it but I don't know hold
in Quentin Tarantino knows the answer to
that question I think so because because
they show him like beat up Bruce Lee
right like on the set I mean there is a
very well-known and true story of gene
choking out stevens the gold till he
[ __ ] his pants on set but it could be
based on that or it could just be you
know confidence okay so so we've
established who gene LeBell is now like
I'm just so excited to share my
experience with them as it's like
something that that like the world never
got to see everything like gene LeBell
showed up when we showed up on the set
and and when I say on the set
the the office for Jackass the movie
our first jackass movie and they had if
I remember correctly like the entire
cast like what were there nine of us and
I believe he did all nine of us we were
we were in a row and he came up one by
one and and choked us out
we're unconscious and he laid us down on
the ground where we kind of like touched
a little bit but then wake up and and
you would think going through nine
people if it was nine or six or however
many you would picture that taking a
long time however he [ __ ] it was like
he just squeezed and and we were out
like at the way I remember in such a
short time it was like counterintuitive
it was hard to even like believe then we
were completely unconscious so fast and
he laid his downs like like out Lina out
later and it was just the systematic
down the line and it was so artful it
was so [ __ ] so [ __ ] impressive and
I remember just think it wasn't even
like particularly scary like to you know
it just happened so fast
and ultimately it was deemed by the
powers that be being spike jonze you
know Johnny Knoxville dread that it was
too dark you know and and perhaps to
imitatable you know if we if we go and
include something then you know we're
exposing ourselves to litigation if if
like you know kids just go out and copy
it so it just it never saw the light of
day but interestingly now my story gets
longer from having that experience our
buddy rest in peace Ryan done Ryan done
came away from that gene LeBell shoot
just for some [ __ ] reason that I can
never understand he walked away from
that feeling educated and qualified to
go and start choking people out himself
and he did
I mean sane and like this is what
happened we were on this tour after that
movie like touring around the whole
[ __ ] world you know with steve-o's
don't try this at home tour doing dumb
getting drunk on stage every night and
Ryan would say to the crowd who wants to
get on stage and get choked unconscious
I'm gonna choke someone out and
everyone's like me me and I'm sitting
there Brian no right you can't just you
can't do this dude
you can't pull people out of the
audience and [ __ ] strangle them
unconscious like no and I was like I
would go into a fit I would like I would
I wouldn't even be on stage I would like
leave the [ __ ] stage and I'd be so
stressed out like no I can't [ __ ] Danny
would do it night after night and then
one night
one morning I should say I'm all [ __ ]
up all coked out like for like three
days in a row
and I'm trying to make a DVD out of this
whole tour which like is is coming up
short on footage because it's like
Groundhog's Day every day for the same
routine and there's nothing to put in
the I'm think I need something really
crazy and so I'm all [ __ ] up this
morning still awake all drunk I go Ryan
[ __ ] choked me out and so so he
chokes me out once and and and then
we're all we'd like to do it again and
he ended up choking me out six times in
one day I believe it was all in one
afternoon
damn like and it took each time and it
wasn't like gene LeBell it was like I'm
like it was so scary like because it
wasn't quick you know it was like and
I'm just like I can't breathe I'm
claustrophobic I'm like I [ __ ] hate
being choked out and and as the as it
went along or longer and longer that
each time it took me longer to wake up
like it was just more and more
disturbing and to make it more exciting
towards the end he's dropping me likes
throwing me down where I'm landing on my
head like it was just [ __ ] up and then
I don't think I ever got choked out
again until Tim Kennedy did it during my
comedy special and my first cup my first
coming and I asked him to lift me up and
drop me and and boy did he like my head
bounced off the stage that that has to
be among the worst concussions have ever
had
and then I was up in the mountains in
Peru where I found this one right here
Wendy and and should Chuck Liddell
choked me out so that's like that's a
bunch of times
damn did any case that was my gene
LeBell story which I took way too far
you know don't do it anymore but it's do
like the reason why he'd drop you so
quick as he was tickle blood blood choke
by cutting off your blood and I your
windpipe so I can hear Chuck takes a
long time
blood chokes real quick have someone
like lift your feet up after you're out
so it makes the blood rush back to your
head don't let him drop you down your ID
dude like come on now you guys are brain
I know I'm not I'm not doing it anymore
and I don't encourage anybody to do it
but from that from what from what I
understand the actual being choked out
isn't particularly dangerous it's just
the being dropped on your head that you
want to worry about right mm-hmm
Yeah right that's not good so you don't
you know definitely don't want to give
yourself brain trauma after your brain
is deprived of oxygen it's just double
trouble I've paid zero attention to time
over here but but I feel like I've kept
you for for age long has it been Scott
we're at one hour and six minutes okay
that's not too bad but we could probably
start wrapping it up here pretty soon
I wanted to Rhonda I wanted to also draw
some attention to all the great stuff
that you do for like charity and all
these or like I understand you've got
multiple organizations and initiatives
to to give back to the community and it
helps um certain causes um well I mean
there's I related to try not to toot my
own horn but like I have a gaming stream
by stream on the planet and instead of
collecting donations for myself during
the stream which a lot of people do I
really don't need to so instead we like
pick a different
charity every stream to like raise money
for okay good so that's kind of like an
ongoing thing we're not just bringing
money to like different areas of extreme
but we're also like promoting and
bringing awareness and telling people
about it every stream so we've doing a
lot of like coronavirus themed charities
lately you know we were doing uh feeding
America which helps people that you
actually get food while they're
quarantined to be able to stay
quarantined we were doing some stuff for
United Nations Foundation which was
matching all of the World Health
Organization funds to look for care for
coronavirus and god there's like a
different one every stream hi Chuck he's
the best he's a big boy
but man it really is like a different
way my own my fair ones raise money for
is actually didi Hirsch which does
nonprofit mental health services in less
like the Los Angeles area so like if you
have like any problem with any kind of
mental illness or it's like you know
depression or suicide or eating
disorders or pie dysmorphia or you name
it they offer like free resources for
people that otherwise you would have to
have enough money to pay for therapy or
these are the kinds of things they offer
all those different things for free
which is one of my favorite things to
like help out but yeah there's just so
many every stream I like literally I
like they've all fallen out of my brain
all I remember is rising zero Don how do
we get people on to your gaming stream
you said it's the baddest baddest ring
on the planet on Facebook gaming we're
gonna be trying to regularly every
Monday now so I'm gonna be doing it this
Monday but yeah I like mostly just check
out my social and everything and I go
like live on Instagram or whatever tell
people whenever I'm bound to go live and
I try to promote you know days leading
up to it but we're still like kind of
figuring it out you're actually
witnessing our brand new battle station
which is like 2l
desks like put together in like a you
nice which is like gonna be building it
we have three computers on it right now
I think it's eventually going to be six
so we're still like kind of figuring
things out and trying to find our rhythm
but yeah it's on Facebook gaming and
yeah so you're you're an avid gamer I am
avid yeah I'm have you said have you
have you said which game you're
particularly fond of well I started
playing Pokemon because I've been
playing Pokemon since forever and I love
it I also really love World of Warcraft
I probably spent the most time playing
World of Warcraft these days but for
International Women's Day I started
playing horizon zero dawn and I am
absolutely obsessed with it since then
so it's kind of like my trifecta and I
do like Pokemon arises yo Don and then
world Warcraft but we like play
different stuff I try to do like a
different indie game every stream to
because like well I'm just kind of
downloading like new indie titles and
just seeing like how they are and
sometimes you find like really really
good stuff or super cheap and I kind of
like want to be I'll go out there and be
like that tester for people and I'll
just go and buy all of them and just try
them all out good but yeah I don't know
man it's kind of like especially like
mmo's are the only like really normal
social interaction that they get with
people what's that mm oh I'm a massive
multiplayer online okay it's like like
World of Warcraft and it's like when a
bunch of people are playing a game at
the same time and then you just end up
playing with people and like forming
relationships without you know I guess
anonymous in a way so I kind of just
kind of like play with people and not
like as like Ronda Rousey like I just
get to be like that's like I feel this
this work or whatever like my guys Scott
who's been so uh so patient and and and
quiet Scott Randolph my co-host who came
to your house for the goat walk as well
is it going now you guys you guys been
doing so great I just been watching it
myself this is fantastic
okay I think it's been pretty I knew it
was gonna be awesome and
and a [ __ ] superstar in every sense
like gene LeBell says about you about
how a lot of people are champions in the
sport but but you're a champion as a
person and I feel strongly the same way
myself and with that said I I know that
while Scott has been super patient and
just sitting there quietly I know that
he's got questions that he's just dying
to ask so Scott like I took me on the
spot right here
no thanks T I just had a couple
questions and I was thinking that you
know as you guys were talking like you
know I mean where my mind can go so many
different directions from this but like
that feeling the one question that comes
to mind is the feeling walking out onto
the platform whether it's the the
Olympics the UFC or or WWE it's like our
Scout Strikeforce and Strikeforce like
like when you're making appearance on
the first time of those things is there
a different feeling going on like like
[ __ ] this is the Olympics this is crazy
you know is it different than when
you're walking out for the first time to
the WWE like what's what's that like
well I think the Olympics kind of made
me max out on pressure in a way you know
like it was my first real like passion
and goal and obsession I ever since
young as I can remember like when I was
six I started swimming like I wanted to
win the Olympics in swimming and I was
something I would dream about something
in my mind all the time and like you
know my my mom and dad were very much
they were really encouraging to me and
my sisters and they're basically just
like you're meant to be the best at
anything you want to be you could be
President
Wenonah Bix whatever you want so I
started doing swimming and my dad's like
you're gonna win the Olympics you're so
great at this and so I just assumed that
that was like my destiny it was like to
win the Olympics and so then when I
switched from swimming to judo I'm like
oh this is Olympic sport I don't know
when the Olympics at this now and I was
just like my obsession from day one is
I'm gonna win the Olympics at this and
so
is a one-day event you know it's not
like swimming where you get to be in ten
different events and give it ten shots
it's like you weigh in one day a few
hours later you start to fight your
matches back to back to back to back and
you'll have up to seven you know four to
seven matches in one day and you go from
weigh-ins to the finals across one day
so it is like I worked my entire life
with the idea that all of my life's work
was going to come down to a showdown on
one day and I was fortunate enough to go
to two Olympics so I kind of had to face
that moment twice and nothing else
really compared to that kind of pressure
that I put on myself so you know even
with fights with championship fights
it's you you have them over and over and
over and over and over so like it wasn't
like okay you're gonna have one
championship fight and then it's gonna
be for years so you can have another one
it's like oh there's gonna be another
one in a few months a few months and a
few months and so that was like much
less pressure than the Olympics and then
for WWE it was just like fun and game
this in comparison you know like
everybody there's expiring for
conspiring first I'll succeed this is
great like I remember walking out to
Wrestlemania I just felt like you know
like that was like the coolest part of
my day like that was it like oh my god
it's WrestleMania because at that point
it was my third WrestleMania by the time
that I was headlining WrestleMania I was
first of all I was like I had 14
stitches in my leg from kicking open a
card window and a couple of days before
that so I was like ow I was also tired
from like a whole year being on the road
so I was like oh my god I get to go home
after this is all so and then it was
basically like oh it's like a big party
I had [ __ ] Joe Jets here you know and
it's like walking out to like granny
hobby like it kind of like reminded me a
lot of like hosting SNL where it was
like a week of just non-stop and in the
24 hours like I feel like the 24 hours
before I actually went alive for SNL I
got zero sleep like at all and I
remember like Tina Fey is out there
doing Sarah Palin and they're about to
hit the music and I was really like
slapping myself like wake up get hyped
like do this and like they like drilled
me the point that I always just could
not be nervous anymore and I just went
out there and did it and it was very
much like that for the main event at
WrestleMania where I was just like I
knew that I had it down like I was just
[ __ ] exhausted and I was gonna be
really happy when this was done well and
done okay yeah it was I didn't and it
was really kind of funny seeing like
Charlotte Becky there you know and so
I'm so maxed out on on high-pressure
situations I feel like that actually got
to enjoy it more than anybody else
because everybody else was like oh my
god the pressure and I was like this
cool you know the it's like depreciated
over time the pressure I guess was was
your walk out song always Joan Jett bad
reputation
no originally it was sex and violence by
the exploited nice so time said I wasn't
allowed to use it then I tried to feel
other songs I feel right and then before
my first title match I decided to go
with Joan Jett and and you stuck with it
suck up stuck with it was good luck you
know yeah [ __ ] right on you know
succinctness like my anthem for life but
I'm like of course it's gotta be Joan
Jack she's like kick
yeah oh my god she's so cool dude like
she's so much cooler it'll ever be I got
to finally meet Joan Jett vania she's
like yeah
[Music]
as far as cool stuff cuz you just
mentioned hosting Saturday Night Live
Wow yesterday jeez that second span
you've been on The Ellen Show I presume
yeah I love Ellen
she's like the bluest eyes ever oh my
god Scott went what else can you think
of as like the coolest [ __ ] things
you could like you've been on Leno like
okay I just have Fallon and it's Colbert
yeah I've done in all of the night shows
yeah what do you think about Howard
Stern I'd be been on there yeah he was
really nice and he actually drew me a
little sketch of himself a little
thank-you note and I thought that was
really sweet super cool so so in
conclusion you're a [ __ ] superstar
you've done it all you've been
absolutely everywhere and none of this
has changed to you art if anything
you're just surprisingly grateful and
humble and you know it's it's pretty
inspirational everything about you and
thank you well don't tell anybody I have
a caring treatment to maintain you know
it's cool too because like when I post a
photo of you and me on my Instagram
people are like how is she I'm like
couldn't be nicer
you know of all the people that I meet
with Steve it's like the most
down-to-earth person and couldn't be
nicer and and I really appreciate that
too so I will not tell anybody I think
that yeah I think we have that in common
Rhonda that people assume that I'm gonna
be like wildly different than I actually
am yeah like utilizing that perception
to our advantage instead of being slave
to trying making it as accurate right
truth as possible is something that like
I think you've really been able to
benefit from and I have to you know
I like to be a heel antagonist and all
of the different worlds I operate in and
it it it's how like I'm able to operate
be as be a professional and kind of like
separate myself from that you know and
kind of keep something like kind of
secret and private for myself and like
you know like when you start to like
rise and visibility it's everybody else
it changes you know you're the one that
stays the same and you can let because
we are such social creatures when
everybody else changes and you become
you get in an unhealthy social situation
it could become psychologically
unhealthy I think that very good I think
that's your experience with it because
because like generally my understanding
is that when people become famous that
there are inherent growing pains
involved I know that I certainly did you
know I had them I was like wait a second
hold on like people would do whatever I
want
you know like I can act out sexually
with strangers like hold on like I can
like you know like I definitely abused
the powers that came with notoriety like
as fast as possible and as much as
possible and I'm grateful to have sort
of made it over that hump during a time
when like there wasn't a video camera in
everybody's pocket like and and for that
matter I'm so grateful to have been
clean and sober and and you know working
a spiritual program for 12 years which
is longer than everybody's had video
cameras in their pockets yeah well you
know I think you you had your first
draft in front of the whole world you
know like I kind of had like a rough
draft of famous Fame and visibility
through judo so it was kind of my
goodness like you're also you're also a
better person right
I also was a fleet so there was always
something I really had to focus on
despite all of the other peripheral
things that were going on so I kind of
like learned a lot of lessons in judo
that I was able to kind of apply the
second time around through the you have
seen even when [ __ ] was the biggest and
craziest possible in the UFC it was like
I I was the most active champion that
they ever had I Oh Dana so much for
taking a leap of faith for me that I
could never say no no no to if I in my
life so I always was like just trying to
[ __ ] keep myself from collapsing from
exhaustion because I had another fight
ahead of me I didn't have time for sex
drugs and rock and roll because I had a
[ __ ] fight you know I had the record
actually here's the record I was the
record for the fastest successful title
defense in UFC history because I beat
Sara McMann 56 days after I beat Misha
the second time and there's all these
little records all over the place of you
know I fought on more February's in
August's than [ __ ] anybody which are
like the lowest paper few months you
know because I just needed to be able to
be there for the company whenever they
asked because they were there for me
when nobody had faith in me and that was
like kind of like how I was trying to
make the way and set a standard for the
money that the women are getting paid I
also kind of want to make the way and
pay off of all the favors for kind of
allowing the woman in the door so now
all the women after me kind of don't
feel that pressure because I feel like
like hopefully I alleviated that from
for them yeah sure and I don't know how
we went this far into the podcast
without you know the probably the
greatest thing I mean I think it to take
someone like Dana Way and who I just am
such a [ __ ] fan of I think Dana
White's the coolest dude ever and like
you know clearly he's the [ __ ] man
you know what he says goes and and he
says there's never gonna be any women in
the UFC and then he turns around and
a hundred percent because of you well I
never see that while I was trying to
come up in MMA and I remember thinking
like that's just cuz he hasn't met me
yet
he doesn't know like III like I knew
that was like we're gonna be [ __ ] best
friends like I do it but yeah I also
forgave him for that assumption because
he hadn't met me yet he had no reason to
think otherwise I love it and and and
it's like credit to him for being so
absolutely candid about the fact that
you single-handedly like brought I mean
I watched a YouTube video of your UFC
Hall of Fame package and you know it
said it all pretty well you know like
Daniel Cormier said that he broke down
barriers for gender barriers like ever
like just everything every [ __ ]
barrier like it's it's pretty killer I
love it hey Ron I gotta ask one question
and we can cut this out if you want is a
who's a cooler boss to work with Dana
White or Vince McMahon well Vince is
pretty [ __ ] cool but Dana's one of my
best friends yeah Dana wife the man did
I respected lovesick man but you know I
Thanos my [ __ ] dude like yeah he like
teaches me still it inspires me a lot
and he like really is he's not just like
you know a great business partner and
someone that I have a lot of respect for
but he's like someone like near and dear
to my heart who I there's a lot of
things I disagree with him about but I
respect his you know perspective and he
does mine and he we can disagree about
things and go back and forth and one
thing that I really love about him is
we're able to not word things right with
each other you know like we're able to
say things the wrong way and it won't be
like what the [ __ ] you know something
like that like he can say something
and it's totally the wrong way and he
mean it the other way and it's not going
to snowball into something else like
okay just just tell me what you mean cuz
me and mean Dana have had our days of
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you know we're
like really close friends it is just
like it's not like that the end or
something like that and always like well
the both of us later be like oh man I'm
sorry about that and yeah you know like
he's deeply inspires me a lot and that
he like he just doesn't let [ __ ] get to
him like [ __ ] just rolls off of his
shoulders that would really bother me a
lot he's had a lot of people like betray
him and you know like really kind of
things that would happened to him would
just make me completely become callous
and close myself off and he's really
stopped me from becoming super cows and
closing myself off when he said all of
that B reason earth that do the same
himself and he just literally just [ __ ]
just bounces off of them and I don't
know how he does it and it's really
inspiring in a lot of ways how he just
like is so sure of who he is in himself
that other people not knowing that
doesn't bother him at all because he is
so sure of himself and yeah we we learn
a lot from each other and you know I'm
not perfect he's not perfect but I
[ __ ] love him to death and he had
faith in me when nobody else did it I
will never ever forget it I don't know
if you could say that nobody had faith
in me because I think that the the truth
of the matter is that you are so
undeniable that you had proven yourself
like to such a stratospheric level that
he just had to bring you into the UFC so
but he didn't he didn't have to though
you know guys alright dad you already
bought out Strikeforce and they'd
absorbed Talent and folded every other
place that they bought and there was a
very short window of time where I was is
like they are already bringing over
Strikeforce talent and they are about to
close this [ __ ] organization and I
have this [ __ ] window to convince him
to bring over all
the women before folding strikeforce
yeah it was in hindsight it seems like
oh of course but in that short [ __ ]
window of time it was a leap of faith
and completely unproven and thank God he
likes to gamble again you win and you're
right so [ __ ] yeah man and we're such
huge fans of the UFC and of Dana White
and just a view of everything thank you
so much for doing this and it's Lucy
right now this is Wendy yeah one day
I'll be able to see Wendy and the van
yeah I thought the van was named Lucy
van is Ruby very close pretty sure yeah
are you guys okay with the screen grab
just in case we need it let me let me do
this um Rhonda Todd talks talk so I can
see you um because it only shows who's
talking okay
I'm Jack I can now look that way I can't
a little bit more this way I can't look
back a little back that way okay now
without looking at me and answered this
quote this question where do women with
no legs work I don't know I don't know
either but it's crawling with [ __ ]
thumbnail game is strong how about the
[ __ ] podcast game was strong on this
one
Thank You Rhonda and thank you to
everybody who's still with us as I've
done at the end of each of these
podcasts I like to say if you're still
listening and
I've been from the very beginning but
last time I said I do a screenshot on
Instagram and tag me in it
well I [ __ ] threw a like on every
single one of those posts like I mean I
can't believe got many of them there are
this is great [ __ ] that just so dude
again like let your friends know
whatever screenshot tagged me and I will
throw a like on it and bless you all man
we're gonna keep this train rolling I'm
sorry that the world is [ __ ] up but
you know we're gonna keep doing this
[ __ ] so hopefully that helps I love you
all yeah